bull sharks bite with more force
pound-for-pound than any other species
of large shark but in Texas waters they
don't frequently turn their teeth on
humans that is until 2010
three attacks in less than a year the
safety and livelihood of local residents
is under threat Galveston is a tourism
Mecca but having a bunch of shark
attacks in a short span makes people
question whether to go to the beach all
three attacks take place in the waters
off of Galveston Island
so wildlife journalist Chester Moore
returns to the scene to search for clues
that may shed light on the mystery and
near the water's edge he spies something
striking this is an incredible plant
called Sargassum Sargassum is a floating
seaweed much of it originates in the
Sargasso Sea
a vast 3,000 mile long stretch of ocean
in the North Atlantic but closer to home
chester has noticed something sinister
this seaweed seems to attract sharks but
I'm out there fishing and I see a bunch
of sarcasm I know I'm probably gonna
catch sharks what is it about this tiny
plant that appeals to sharks and how
could it explain the spike in attacks
biologist Larry McKinney has been
studying the Texas coastline for more
than 40 years he says the answer may
come down to what lies hidden within
Sargassum this is a mobile habitat the
seaweed provides food refuge and
breeding grounds for an array of
critters the types of animals that are
associated with Sargassum are
particularly small starting with small
crabs and shrimp these animals in turn
attract a variety of larger species like
fish and sea turtles the preferred prey
of sharks any place that would
concentrate a food source shark will
always come
normally Sargassum floats to the texas
shore in small bits and pieces today we
have kind of a normal amount of
Sargassum but around the time of the
attacks something changed what I'm
looking at here are satellite
photographs of the coast of Texas during
2010-2011 if you look just offshore now
each one of these green dots these are
big patches of Sargassum they were
coming in mats that were the size of a
football field you can actually see
Sargassum from space
[Music]
in Galveston the seaweed buries the
beach in huge heaps experts believe this
sudden influx of Sargassum may be the
result of a variety of environmental
factors including strong winds and a
steady rise in ocean temperatures and
the seaweed invasion isn't limited to
Texas beaches in Florida the Caribbean
West Africa and South America are all so
inundated no matter what they tried to
do to clean it up within a few days more
we're coming ashore it's a worldwide
Sargassum siege
could sharks be following this seaweed
snack into the Texas shallows thereby
increasing the risk of an accidental
run-in with humans
according to McKinney sharks do follow
the mess but only so far well you see
most of the fish feeding on Ferguson is
out past these breakers once it gets up
into these sandbars and starts rolling
over and over the small animals do drop
out and they disperse
so once the seaweed reaches the shallows
where humans are it loses its appeal so
the idea that Sargassum attracted sharks
into this area it's probably not very
likely
[Music]